in this video I want to talk about the
structure of the disaccharides which are
just two sugar two simple sugars put
together two monosaccharides and
polysaccharides which are many sugars
long okay so I'm going to kind of draw
them out starting off with maltose so
maltose is essentially that wellies the
way I learned it was one alpha D glucose
plus one beta-d-glucose okay so and
they're these these two are connected
via a an alpha 1-4 glycosidic bond so
what does this mean what is alpha 1-4
glycosidic bond what does this mean
right we should know the structures of
alpha D glucose and beta-d-glucose by
now right so if we're drawing an alpha D
glucose it's going to look like this so
glucose right was milk dud if we're
talking about alpha D glucose we've got
down up down right but now so it's going
to be an alpha D Tweel so the O H would
be down but the thing is this is not
going to be an O it's going to be
connected to the beta-d-glucose okay let
me twice because it's an alpha 1-4
glycosidic bond so what is that sort of
getting at if you remember numbering the
carbons six five four three two one
this alpha one four the one refers to
carbon number 1 on the first thing which
is the Alpha D glucose and the four
refers to the second the second what's
called so if we call this molecule a and
this molecule B then this is referring
to a
this is referring to the connection on B
so when we draw the the beta-d-glucose
it's going to actually be connected here
like this so let me actually draw it out
and kind of explain it upon drawing it
out so this is going to be a
beta-d-glucose oh it's still down up and
then down
but this the connection here occurred
via dehydration synthesis we got rid of
an H an H and O H which is just the
water to form this covalent bond between
the two okay so this was down up and
this is still pointing down here right
so this is ch2oh R this is molecule a
right this is a which is the Alpha D
glucose and this is D beta D glucose
here I mean fill in all these Oh H is
here all right this is a beta D glucose
to the edge on the anomeric carbon is
going to be pointing up so this here
this disaccharide is multo s' right one
alpha D glucose connected to one
beta-d-glucose now let me go through a
number of these carbons here we have six
five four three two one so what are they
talking about with this alpha 1-4
glycosidic bond
well the Alpha comes from the fact that
this n Americ carbon is alpha right and
this is carbon number 1 so alpha and one
come from molecule number 1 or molecule
a right now the 4 comes from the fact
that we're binding this carbon here the
carbon that that we're connecting to on
the second sugar is right there is
carbon number 4 so this is an alpha 1-4
glycosidic bond that's the name for the
bond between two sugars okay so that's
maltose next up is lactose so lactose is
one beta D galactose plus one
beta-d-glucose connected via a beta 1-4
glycosidic bond alright so we're going
to have an alpha or a beta D galactose
and I've n a beta D glucose so beta D
galactose like this loop with a four at
the O up here on this multi so here
there we go now that's maltose so beta D
galactose so D means it's going to have
this going on up here ch2oh down up up
four galactose right and let's number
these carbons so we've got carbon number
six five four three two and one okay so
one's going to be beta which means it's
going to be going up right so again
we're going to have we're going to have
lost the water here okay so now this is
going to be connected to to the fourth
carbon on the beta-d-glucose so the
fourth carbon on the beta-d-glucose
would be pointing down so it looks
something like this so this is going to
be a beta-d-glucose so ch2oh down up
down which is why I do that connection
in that fashion right and this is going
to be a beta-d-glucose so the Oh H is
going to be going up
alright so now does this all make sense
six five four three two one
beta one four so is this a beta on four
linkage well this is carbon number one
so this portion here is correct this
this oh this this bond is going up which
is the same direction as a ch2oh this
beta portion is correct
four is it connected to carbon number
four on the next thing yep that's
correct this is a beta one four
glycosidic bond and that is lactose okay
cool next up we're going to draw sucrose
sucrose is kind of funny to draw but
it's a it's one alpha D glucose plus one
beta d fructose and it's connection is
an alpha oops
an alpha beta one two glycosidic bond is
a little bit interesting
okay so what's what is this right so up
here we had just an out of beta right
now we have an alpha beta what does that
mean okay well let's draw it and see
what we can get
so when we have the alpha D glucose well
we know what that looks like that looks
like this down up down because it's
glucose ch2oh up because d the circle up
here oh goodness I forgot the circle up
here the O up there too
so now this is alpha D glucose which
means that it's oh isn't it pointing
down now that means so alpha is about
this carbon here right so this is always
going to be down beta so alpha and one
kind of go together okay let's see if we
can make sense of this the alpha and the
one go together and the beta and the two
go together so the alpha or should be
the beta and the two are part of this
and the alpha and the one are part of
this so this is the 1 carbon first of
all let's go back in number these
carbons so we remember these carbons
we've got 6 5 4 3 2 1 so here this this
one carbon is going to be alpha that
makes sense here okay it's going to be
connected
it to the beta 2 carbon on fructose so
let me draw this out because it's kind
of funny how this works out it's kind of
weird so this is going to be connected
to sucrose like this so sucrose looks
our zuny fructose looks like this okay
so if it's beta d fructose have a ch2oh
like that four doses up and down okay
and it's beta the O H would be going up
but now let's not forget for toast is a
six carbon molecule right so it's ch2oh
has to be coming down here so let's just
make sure that we have all those correct
six five four three two one
what does this make sense this here this
anomeric carbon carbon number one is
alpha so alpha and one check out right
because this this Oh H would have been
down relative to the ch2oh opposite
sides so alpha and one go together this
fructose here is a beta D fructose this
this Oh H is going up same size as this
ch2oh so it's beta and this is on carbon
number two right this is why we have the
second thing here it's not just an alpha
1 2 linkage this beta specifies here
that the the linkage is it's linked to
the anomeric carbon here so this here is
sucrose okay
one thing I wanted to point out before I
moved on to what some of the
polysaccharides is that that these two
these first two maltose and lactose they
both have at there an America Arbonne
they have free o H groups okay so the
fact that that H is there makes them
able to reduce another compound okay so
because they have that free o H group
they're hanging off the end they all
what's called reducing sugars okay
so they can this this Oh H can reduce
something else and ends become oxidized
and become a proper new
group okay so these are both reducing
sugars however is sucrose a reducing
sugar well it's an America Arbonne it
does not have a free o H no free o age
group so it is not a oops nice sugar and
excuse me how they reducing sugar okay
we're these ones they both have free o
age groups at the nm Eric carbon at the
end okay so this goes the same thing for
this one okay so that's sucrose a couple
more things I want to mention I
mentioned cellulose so cellulose is
basically it's a polysaccharide so those
first those first three these first
three we're disaccharides right just to
two monosaccharides put together
cellulose is a bunch of beta-d-glucose
--is connected or linked via beta one
four linkages or glycosidic bond okay so
the way they look is kind of like this
if we have beta d glucoses i've one
beta-d-glucose here ch2oh down up down
beta so it's going up okay
next connect it to another one via one
four linkage so the fourth one the
fourth one is down so it's going to look
like this goodness I keep forgetting
those O's they're my apologies down up
down
is also going up right and now this is
going to be connected to another one
cetera et cetera but the point is here
six five four three two one six five
four three two one
the linkage here is indeed a beta one
four linkage okay now so this is just a
bunch of glucoses connected together but
that's also what's starch and glycogen
are starch and glycogen are also just a
bunch of glucose is put together starch
and glycogen also just a bunch of
glucose is but specifically there are a
bunch of alpha D glucose is linked via
alpha one four linkages right so they're
going to look a little bit different
they're going to have alpha D glucose is
going to look like this down up down if
it's a one four linkage this is an alpha
so go down I'm going to connect to the
the next glucose which is alpha and it's
going to look like this
down up alright this is also going alpha
so that's going to be connected to the
next one right and so that it's a long
string of these okay is this an alpha
one four linkage well let's go back a
number the carbon six five four three
two one six five four three two one
so here we've got whoops here we've got
the one carbon it's alpha because it's
the the bond is pointing down this and
this one's pointing up with those so
they're trans is the one carbon
connected to the fourth carbon so this
is indeed an alpha one four linkage just
as this was a beta one four
linkage now humans cannot digest
cellulose we do not even though there's
just a bunch of glucoses together just
like starch and glycogen are we do not
have the enzyme that allows us to digest
cellulose we can't digest this beta
linkage however we can digest starch and
glycogen because we do have the enzyme
that breaks up this alpha linkage okay
so that's something to keep in mind this
is why we we can eat things like rice
and potatoes right and digest them and
use them and break up those glucose and
use those glucoses for energy through
glycolysis which we'll talk about in the
future but we can digest things like
grass or paper right we can't we can't
digest paper we don't eat napkins our
bodies don't recognize those as things
that we could break down for for woo
Coast so that is definitely the case one
thing I forgot to mention that I did
want to go back to was that lactose is
some people are lactose intolerant so
what if you are indeed lactose
intolerant it's likely that you do not
have the enzyme that can break up this
beta linkage okay so those individuals
who are lactose intolerant cannot break
down that don't have the enzyme lactase
which breaks that down okay so I hope
that overview of disaccharides and
polysaccharides was helpful I'll also
post a video of the PDF that I use to
kind of put this together so I hope that
was helpful